fin
bonjour à tous je suis ses coûts et le
packtec vous savez ce qu'est le conseil
de prud'hommes je vous explique
aujourd'hui de quoi il s'agit le conseil
de prud'hommes c'est quoi le conseil de
prud'hommes est un tribunal du travail
il est compétent pour régler les
différends et les litiges qui peuvent se
produire entre un employeur et un
salarié ou un ex salarié de qui est
composé de conseils de prud'hommes le
conseil de prud'hommes se compose de
juges élus par les salariés et par les
employeurs tous les cinq ans
également appelés conseillers
prud'hommes il peut s'agir soit de
conseillers employeurs soient de
conseillers salariés
les conseillers prud'hommes ont les
mêmes pouvoirs qu'ils soient salariés ou
employeurs
chaque conseil de prud'hommes et présidé
alternativement chaque année tantôt par
un conseiller salarié tantôt par un
conseiller employeur
chaque conseil de prud'hommes et chaque
section de ce conseil comprend autant de
juges salariés que deux juges employeur
il s'agit d'une juridiction paritaire
quels sont les sections du conseil de
prud'hommes le conseil se divise en cinq
sections autonomes correspondant aux
différents secteurs d'activité
c'est-à-dire
l'agriculture l'industrie le commerce la
fonction de cadre et les activités
diverses telles que les activités
artistiques l'enseignement l'aide à
domicile et cetera
l'appartenance du conseiller prud'homme
à une section est déterminé en fonction
de l'activité principale de son
employeur chaque section se décompose en
un bureau de conciliation et un bureau
de jugement la conciliation et la
première phase de la procédure
elle est obligatoire durant cette phase
un conseiller employeur et un conseiller
salariés tentent de mettre d'accord
l'employeur et le salarié concerné
si cette phase de conciliation n'aboutit
pas l'afer est alors traitée devant le
bureau de jugement c'est à dire que la
sphère va être jugé
il y à plus de 250 conseil de
prud'hommes répartis dans les différents
départements de france y at il un
conseil de prud'hommes à la réunion oui
bien sûr il en existe deux l'un à saint
denis et l'autre à fouquières le conseil
de prud'hommes est donc une juridiction
qui a une compétence sociale qui est de
régler les conflits entre employeurs et
salariés à bientôt dans un nouvel
épisode